this has been a pretty amazing week for
trailers I mean we already had the
Batman comic-con thing and now we have a
new trailer for interstellar today's
Christopher Nolan's birthday and on the
website you get to enter a very special
cone you could then view the trailer
here's the code right now it's awesome
how Nolan always is very secretive about
this he makes it very fun for his fans
to be able to experience his films as
well as his trailers and once again this
trailer does not spoil anything you get
little morsels little things that hint
at greatness much bigger things the
trailer starts out with McConaughey
talking about how humans used to look to
the stars and imagine what's up there
and now all we can think about is our
place in the dirt
this trailer hints that the movie is
largely about mankind trying to find
another place to live where they can
then find resources from someplace else
to continue to survive and one of the
things I'm really happy about is that
you get just a few insert shots of
things that they discover out in space
so they definitely go to space there's
definitely discoveries of other awesome
places and other things and that was
something I was concerned about I was
like is it just gonna be about thinking
about going to space thinking about
interstellar travel are we actually
going to go on a space adventure and
we're going this is my most anticipated
film for the rest of the year in fact it
has been my most anticipated for the
entire year I cannot wait to go see this
movie I can't wait to hear Hans Zimmer's
new score Matthew McConaughey has
continued to impress me as an actor he's
been doing amazing work lately and he
looks like this is gonna be one of his
best he recently said in an interview
this is Christopher Nolan's most
ambitious work in his opinion which is
really saying something you actually
hear a few lines from Anne Hathaway this
time as well as West Bentley we are
seeing a little bit more of this cast
coming together
I am so intrigued by how this movie
looks by the mind-blowingly awesome
space imagery I cannot wait to see
interstellar what do you guys think of
this new trailer did it do it for you
because it did it for me are you pumped
for this movie as I am let me know below
and as always guys thank you so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck niced
[Music]